the name of the blog was paleomg right
away right yeah and that's still your
instagram handle yeah still but yet your
diet has taken like many like everyone's
diet i feel like even paleo i mean there
was a diet before paleo that we thought
was the best and then there was a diet
before that that we thought was the best
and we're going to think paleo was
stupid someday with some other diet i'm
sure totally and so you've gone through
different phases on that so before we
get into those things i i actually was
just thinking about this and i was
getting ready to do this with you i
haven't asked you this but you don't eat
paleo yeah necessarily anymore so
like probably quite a bit especially
because of the new bean protocol that
you do um but have you ever thought
about changing that
yeah rebranding i guess that would be
called rebranding essentially right yeah
so i've talked to my team about this who
rebranded my site recently
and
at this point literally all somebody
will see me on the street and say
paleomg they like don't always know my
name they know paleomg sure
and
so it's hard to let go of that identity
a little bit how and we've talked about
letting go of identities in general um
so i definitely plan to change the name
in the future i don't know what that
would be it would just be my own name
because
my llc is my own name so why not just
change it into that um
and that's what my site has really
become just things that i want to share
as a human being because it's not just
paleo food i mean you started with that
to help people but i mean that does
happen a lot where somebody
you know uses whatever they do as the
hook and then but you're that's not all
you are i mean you're everything from
food to workout to inspiration to
fashion i mean there's just so many
different aspects that it doesn't even
encompass everything that you do and
that you're into so that's a normal
that's a normal transition but it's also
a gamble
a little bit because you're getting rid
of the name everyone knows you for too
you know i know
and so it's a hard it's a hard thing to
choose with the shift of the name
i
i don't i just don't know what to be yet
so
i think everything kind of happens when
it's supposed to happen and when
something feels really right i go for it
when it was back in probably i started
my blog in 2011 so it's crazy that i was
23 and now i'm 33 like the
transformation you have in your early
20s to your early 30s like
you can't believe how what how
small-minded you were yeah early 20s if
you've grown is a big growing phase and
i so i've listened to my gut with many
things and in probably 2013 2014 i said
i'm not going to just do recipes i want
this blog to evolve into lifestyle
whatever i want to share if i want to
share fashion if i want to share skin
care if i want to share um a really
personal story that's affecting me and
may help somebody i want to share that
i'm not going to just keep it food and
so i listen to my gut when something's
pulling me in a different direction and
so i think my gut will tell me when it's
time to really shift that name into
something else yeah
but well maybe it'll be
maybe it'll be
being omg yeah
yes okay so you've done this being
protocol but before we get to like your
most recent sort of iteration was there
anything between going from zone to
um
paleo to the bean protocol
was there anything in between that you
you lived in for a while that was
outside of paleo yeah so i did zone i
did paleo super strict and what were the
benefits first off because i think this
is interesting for people like what did
you notice with
zone then what did you notice with
paleo then what did you notice moving
forward from that
zone was portion control it just taught
you how much food you should be
consuming because if you don't know and
if you don't have a really good
connection with your body and i didn't
because i was eating animal crackers
with frosting every day if you don't
have that real connection with your body
and how it should feel and what hunger
cues should feel like and what fullness
should feel like a zone type of diet
or even weight watchers or any of those
can help you understand portion control
more so that gave me an understanding of
portion control paleo gave me an
understanding understanding of nutrient
dense foods
and what it was like to have different
types of vegetables and different types
of protein and what um organic and
grass-fed and grass-finished and
pasture-raised all those different um
ways
meat is brought into our lives and
produce
it gave me a better understanding of
where our food comes from and the
importance of it and how it affects our
body
and
it it made me feel so much better
but what
was really lacking and i didn't
understand was fiber
and that was the biggest lacking in my
life and i didn't understand that for
years and years so once i kind of
stopped doing paleo because i just
didn't feel great and i didn't know what
it was and
i was going through this big stage in my
life where
i was
uh over crossfit i was really inflamed i
was over exercising and i just didn't
feel connected to my body and so i said
am i allowed to cuss on this yeah okay
okay 100
okay
i said [ __ ] it i'm not i'm not doing
this anymore i'm going to do opposite of
what i've been doing for many years what
i thought was right and so if i'm on i
have french fries i'm gonna have french
fries um i still stayed gluten-free
because gluten-free just felt better to
me or just we don't have the best
sources of grains unless you really know
where to look
um
and so i i stayed gluten-free but if i
wanted french fries if i wanted a
dessert if i
um you know wanted to go eat out
somewhere i just let my
life open up a little bit more and had
more flexibility in it had way more
potatoes because white potatoes were so
shamed in paleo and then it kind of
shifted when whole30 said potatoes were
okay right so i started eating more
potatoes um
my carbohydrates actually increased and
i felt better and so i just started
paying attention to my body more instead
of the really high fat diet that i've
been on before i went more higher
carbohydrate and that felt better so i
kind of just did this little shift
and then
years later so this was just
this past year i was introduced to the
bean protocol through another podcast
and the bean protocol is all about fiber
it is all about soluble fiber and
getting any sort of toxins or excess
hormones out of your body and so if
you're dealing with
rosacea eczema if you're dealing with
infl infertility you're dealing with
acne it has a ton of
um a ton to do with the amount of
soluble fiber you're getting into your
diet so i started listening to this
podcast started reading up about the
bean protocol and it was all about beans
which i hadn't eaten in 10 years right
because of the paleo diet right and i
was always like well i get gassy when i
eat beans so my body's telling me to not
have these beans
listening to it
so i thought what do i have to lose i
don't want to have acne anymore and i've
dealt with acne my whole life i've been
on accutane it comes back and i
obviously this is a hormonal thing
that's going on because when i go
through times of stress like when i
almost lost my dog
my acne goes crazy when i over exercise
my acne goes crazy so it's these
hormonal issues are going on so i said
[ __ ] it again and i'm gonna eat these
beans i'm gonna eat beans six times a
day
and
it was did you start out at six or did
you start out with like once a day and
then twice a day or did you just do the
whole over a cheap you overcharged over
two you start with six six hard so how'd
that go so i first quit coffee all
together which is already just the most
punishing thing ever it's so sad it is
so sad and so i started the bean
protocol eating beans six times a day
and i cut out coffee at the same time so
i was having a liver detox effect so
when you say six times a day like a
quarter to a third of a cup yeah i was
having about a fourth of a cup okay yeah
six times a day yeah and then i cut out
coffee so you have this liver detox
effect
while you're having the withdrawals from
coffee and it was it was wild because i
had crazy headaches and i never get
headaches but i also had pain near my
liver what this radiating pain and i had
full body aches like i had the flu
and i was like what is going on this if
this is just full
um addiction to coffee because i was
having like one and a half cups a day
nothing like that's not crazy
and
addiction to coffee and yeah normal
and it made it made me like
question coffee i was like should i not
be drinking this is this is coffee gonna
be the new smoking in the future i mean
based off this there was like i remember
watching this program a long long time
ago
uh it was like drug it was something
about drugs and it was ranking schedule
is like they have scheduled drugs and it
was it was way back in the day and it
was trying to decide which drugs fit
into which schedule of drug like legal
illegal which level and cocaine and
coffee were on the same level
and this is a long time ago so if my
memory doesn't serve me i'm sorry but
this is what i remember and they were on
the same level and then obviously one
was decided to be legal and one's
illegal
so you might be right maybe someday
coffee will be just like hard to find
and illegal and all of a sudden all
kinds of other stuff will be legal that
we never got i've never done cocaine so
i don't know if it feels quite the same
i hope it was a little more exciting
than coffee but that i truly wonder if
that's not as enjoyable because
everybody loves to wake up with their
cup of coffee don't they it was so hard
to change over i was drink drinking like
hot water with lemon
oh terrible terrible
and it's also so ritualistic you know i
think there's a lot of things that we do
in our patterns
in our days that just like
feel like morning
they feel like a like afternoon lunch
snack they feel like friendship fun at
night they feel like friendship there's
like so much routine that we end up
liking and getting used to that make us
feel good and feel normal so wow you
just flip that upside down how did the
bean thing go was it comfortable because
like when i have beans too because i eat
paleo and have since 2000 and
uh well gluten free dairy free starting
in like 2013 and then
paleo starting in 2000
was that 2016 beginning of 2016.
yeah 15 or 16.
it was rough
i farted non-stop
for three months and like thankfully we
were in quarantine at that point like
this was or not yes like
like i'm gonna go take jackson for a
walk that's that's your dog um and we
have a long couch and so we can be on
like separate sides so i could you know
get away with it um it was definitely
rough i'm like is this ever gonna change
yeah and so there's a fermentation stage
that your body goes through with
beans and then once you get past it you
don't deal with that unless you have a
bean that just doesn't maybe work with
your system sure some are worse right
yes so chickpeas um garbanzo beans and
lentils
are rough for me much more gassy yeah
but i'll play around with that and yeah
test it out see if i can get away with a
little bit uh but i still get what kinds
do you eat i do mostly black beans are
like my favorite they just work best for
me pinto beans
um cannellini beans
and butter beans those are the four that
i probably eat the most
and they're easily
available you can find them pretty
easily uh so i started eating beans this
first month i went i dove in i cut out
the coffee i started eating six times a
day and within two weeks my skin started
to clear up
and then within a month my skin had like
half cleared up
and then two months it just continued to
improve and not only did my skin
start to improve but
i i honestly felt leaner
and then my skin was like glowing
everywhere
it was it was crazy how big of a
difference that soluble fiber we should
probably be eating beans right now then
yes i mean you know i have a couple bags
i know i almost had some and then i'm
like well
i got them with me i always pack them
with me when i travel i like pack them
in my taxi most people pack like nuts
most people pack like you know bars you
got beans i got beans even there's like
these little i forget what kind of beans
they are but they're like a snacking
beans so they're like crunchy so you can
pack those okay
so i find little ways to get beans in as
much as possible i blend them into my
smoothies
and you can literally you just get black
beans or pinto beans and butter beans
rinse them off and then put them in your
smoothie and you cannot tell at all and
you just need like a fourth cup sure you
don't need a ton yeah and they just
blend perfectly in there does that help
make them make you less gassy too if
it's like in a drink nope just all the
time i haven't experienced that yet yeah
it's about the same so the three months
came and then it finally cleared up like
you finally like your stomach was normal
yes it only took a month for your skin
to get better and for you to feel better
yeah but then three months three months
it was like my your i guess um
i think i forget what it was something
happens like your skin turns over every
three months or something like that
um so every three months i would see a
drastic change and it would just get i'd
get tremendously better at three months
how i digested the beans and how my skin
looked and so now
my skin really pretty much only acts up
around my period whenever i just have a
hormonal spike but if you pay attention
to when your period is coming you can up
your bean intake to really help get
those hormones out of your body as
they're spiking before wow it's a
medicine yes it is and you can literally
do
two like two tablespoons of beans every
hour every two hours just to get extra
in just to help
because what happens is the hormones
attach to the beans and i'm totally
butchering this like please people if
they're listening to this at least
listen to the professionals who karen
heard or unique hammond they know what
they're talking about um but the
hormones bind to the beans and then
you're able to obviously excrete them
and so the more you get beans into your
diet throughout the day the more
availability it has to cling the
hormones to cling to beans and then you
can get rid of them
so you want to make sure people ask like
well can i just eat like one big serving
a day but if your goal is to really help
with those hormonal issues you want to
get them throughout the day